you know you were talking about the
beginning
you're meeting all this resistance
you're making these videos but uh you
don't know
and a lot of people have this moment
like you know I certainly have this
throughout my 20s is this gonna work am
I gonna make it yeah I headed into my
30s like is this gonna gel do I have a
career uh it's and it's it's terrifying
and you still really haven't answered
that
to be fair you know it's funny I have
not and that's how it feels to me all
the time uh and I it's funny because I
had um I was talking to a bunch of uh
young kids that came in uh to our studio
before we wrap things up and I remember
one of them they all asked questions and
one of them said when do you stop being
nervous and worrying about yeah when
does that stop and I said oh do I have
bad news for you yeah this
woman was like 19 or 20 and I was
telling her it never stops yeah and
um
and she looked a little horrified
um he told her the exact wrong thing I
told her I told her I was I told her the
truth right thing I told her the truth
exactly what she didn't want to hear um
yeah she uh isn't even gonna try and
show business she's an orthopedic
surgeon now making a lot more money but
I know that early on you did have people
that saw something I know Joan Rivers
saw something in you early on and she
really encouraged you right yeah yeah
she was the greatest
um she my first real TV job was a pilot
for Bravo that did not get picked up
because in 2006 if you were gay and
wanted to be on TV they shipped you off
to Bravo
um
literally it was like it was like it was
like an lgbtq orphanage
oh you're talented but you're a gay man
shoving you into a giant FedEx tube and
then putting Bravo on it yeah and
dropping it in the mail that's literally
and it was so odd because I was on stage
in New York doing you know this sort of
Billy on the Street style Persona which
I eventually you know captured in the
videos that we did but that started on
stage so it was this very absurdist
subversive thing that I was doing it was
not Bravo right right but simply because
I was gay they were like all right well
maybe Bravo will do something with you
that was always the answer at the time
which is very funny but also when you
think about it kind of [ __ ] up you
know right I I remember pitching a few
shows to Comedy Central at the time and
the shows revolved around me so you know
they would revolve around a gay man uh
one was a scripted show one was Billy on
the Street I think and what was said to
my face was
well you're brilliant we think you're
hilarious we obviously can't do that
here but I think if you go to Bravo
you'll have a home run yeah like someone
said that to my face thinking that was
like a a helpful thing and then years
later he actually apologized for it
after I was successful but um that's
good I always I always do award points
yeah I have I've had people say terrible
things to me in the early 90s and then
come back later on and admit own it and
say I was wrong and then later come back
and say I was right
it just keeps coming yeah and this is my
dad by the way
there's the old twist ending so this
episode brought to you by Oh Henry um so
so anyway so sure enough Bravo did put
me on a pilot in 2006 and the pilot was
called Joan Rivers Straight Talk and the
idea was it was a prime time version of
The View but instead of Barbara Walters
and four different types of women it was
going to be Joan Rivers and four
different types of gay men talking about
pop culture and politics a panel show
basically and they cast me on the pilot
so Joan came to my live show you know I
auditioned for it and she really liked
me and then she came to check me out on
my live show and she really just loved
what I did she really got me yeah
um and we did that pilot Andy Cohen was
on that pilot before he had his own show
he was on the panel
um Elsie Granderson who's a sports uh
columnist I believe and broadcaster and
another guy and it didn't get picked up
unfortunately but it was an amazing
experience and I got close with Andy
Cohn who's still a good friend and I got
really close with Joan and she really
became like a mentor to me I mean I
could go on and on about how insanely
supportive she was for no reason the
pilot didn't get picked up she had no
reason to deal with me and yet she
really was so helpful Joan you know Joan
this was a few years before Joan had her
Resurgence if you remember and you know
Joan had been blacklisted from a lot of
the late night talk shows like you know
we know this story and she hadn't done
The Tonight Show in many years and
Letterman hadn't had hadn't had her on
in many years just to refresh people's
memory who don't know it was because uh
she had been a huge Star as a guest on
Johnny Carson guest host guest host
that's what I mean a guest host uh and
uh it I mean those that was appointment
television when Joan Rivers was going to
host the Tonight Show and Johnny Carson
was taking a break
um and we're going way back into the 80s
but it was an event because she took the
oxygen out of the room she was so funny
and it was a huge event and then she
went on to do her own show and that was
seen as a betrayal yeah uh she did one
of the first shows on Fox yeah right
when Fox started she did her own late
night show Johnny wasn't leaving the
show his own show at that point so Joan
went and did her own show and he got
extremely mad and basically he had her
blacklisted from late night TV for the
rest of you know her career up until I
don't know like 10 years before she died
uh and so she did have a career
Resurgence though and Letterman did have
her back on and Fallon had her on The
Tonight Show for the first time many
years Kimmel had her on and no one knew
who I was at that point and Joan told me
she said I'm about to do all the late
night shows for the first time in
decades put your Billy on the Street
videos put some of your favorite ones on
a DVD and make copies and leave them at
my apartment and I am going to bring the
producers of all of those shows your DVD
and tell them you have to know this
Billy Eichner guy watch these videos she
had been
blacklisted from late night talk shows
which was so heartbreaking to her for
decades and on her first time back
making the rounds
she reached out to me and said I'm gonna
drop off your DVDs and let these people
know who you are and years later
after she died when I ended up doing
Letterman myself
and doing Kimmel myself I remember the
show Runners at those shows said you
know what's so funny a few years ago
Joan Rivers was here and dropped off
DVDs of you and told us about you before
we knew who you were and which is just
an incredible thing to do it was so
generous and it's clearly she I mean
first of all this is someone who knew
Talent she had I mean her own story is
so incredible yeah uh and what she had
to put up with and what she had to
overcome but then
um
you know it's there are people who
are very passionate about how it should
work and when they see someone who's
good they really feel compelled to get
the word out on them which is a great
quality and not always common there's
plenty of people who see other talented
people and say uh you know maybe feel
threatened by them or think well that's
not my issue that's not my problem yeah
um I've spent a whole career trying to
crush young Talent yeah and you have
successfully there's so many so many
very talented young people that have
never made it because of me that's right
and I and this was just me feeling
insecure and I don't regret it uh part
of your strategy it was part of my
strategy and it helped Elevate me to
crush them congratulations thank you
yeah thank you I did it yeah so many
people you'll never ever see them never
know who they are yeah I tried to crush
you many times remember good luck
[ __ ]
here I am in spite of you in spite of
you you and the Velociraptors and Sonic
the Hedgehog and the guy who ran Comedy
Central and BJ Novak I'm still here
first time I saw Billy on the Street
first time I saw Bill in the street I
was like he's good a little too good he
must be stuck he must be stopped and
remember all those attempts on your life
and you didn't know who was behind it
yeah that's me that was you
well I'm honored honestly